don't be afraid to ask your friends for
help even if they're not trained it's
okay
just be patient take your time with them
and make sure they feel like they're
doing a good job it's always important
to have some extra hands on set also if
you have your friends helping you out
make sure you have food and plenty of it
that's the best way to keep your set and
running try and get cheap if not free
locations for your shoot because you'll
save money for other parts on your
project you'll be surprised how far a
polite request to a manager or owner of
a business or location will get you pro
tip if you don't have a camera ask a
friend you don't have a friend use your
phone if you don't have a phone you
probably get a phone be realistic with
yourself you probably don't have the
money and budget to pull off the
Avengers but you do have what it takes
to pull off a one minute long scene
start simple start basic and finish what
you start
that's how you progress and that's how
you learn if you're searching for ideas
consider looking in the mirror the
things you like and love outside of the
filmmaking world make great stories heck
make something about you and your
friends everyone's done it it works
listen to your gut experiment try new
ideas don't worry about whether or not
they're good it's important for you to
find your voice artistically and
creatively and you're only going to do
that if you don't worry about failure so
just start out doing things making those
experiments and don't worry just do it
at the end of every movie there's a very
long list of credits but remember it's
possible to learn how to do all those
roles yourself so consider that by pro
tip stay organized your footage you're
writing your project files all that
matters in the long run and your future
self will thank you for it
just because it's low-budget doesn't
mean it can't feel cinematic consider
using your camera angles we're lighting
to make things feel larger than life
heck there's a little bunch of stuff all
over here but our angles and lighting
height it off bounce your ideas off of
friends and family before you shoot it
pay attention to their reactions do they
get bored in certain areas do they get
confused in others do you yourself have
trouble trying to explain what's
happening in a certain section this is a
great way to refine your story and your
execution before you actually have to go
shoot it
protip try to get as many people to
watch your edits as possible you'll
never know what they catch that you
might have missed more eyeballs never
hurts listen you are always going to
find things that you can improve on and
make better but it comes to a point
where you just need to finish and move
on the best way to improve your skills
is by making more and more content
iterating just practicing and making
more stuff so just never stop learning
and never stop making content
that's how you are fine you will
eventually little it a important so
close so eyeballs never heard some Union
Union met up higher
[Music]
basically go in the game and actually
recreate these moments in similar
locations so when the guy steals a car
that's the actual sound of stealing car
in the game in that location when he's
at the gun range and shooting a gun
that's the actual sound of shooting a
gun at the gun range so trying to keep
things one-to-one like actually
recreating these moments in the game